alright this is a pepper panic saga level
259 walkthrough tutorial
this is the level is very difficult and
love people and problems with that our
group and
pretty much everywhere so I'm gonna go
ahead and play through it
try to explain things as ago
and talk about setting up these
by pepper mashay to me one thing you can
keep in mind is when you're playing the
the level its long its they can be very
frustrating so
you get aboard like this where you don't
have any real gaps like I don't have
pairs a
to read anywhere that I can carry get
together you know it's just go ahead and
quiet
interrogator for more they said you
don't want to get through her frustrated
just on the very first match so
is never a bad idea to do that
if that's the case it was a little bit
better
because we have so we're part civil
in
but we're all laws for league matches
underneath the
the other word is that this red pepper
right here
know we also have the get-go up
something that this will review
be this is good
that they really are you know we me know
what a move that one down
so we just want to work or on the right
side and
get things to fall into place workers
are first
know a quick look around
it you need to see that there's no
yellow gaps
whatsoever there's barely any other
papers in a row for
so when I'm ready here's
as treasury raise the border as fast as
possible in like you know the purple
we know from from the tapes and
everything that the
for both the last five everest there's
no no reason to try to save that letter
this go ahead and news that the
to clear the board
now look things over their issue
the yellow are set up a little better
for us
right to know your sim
compares these no
area there
this more as is set off to the side to
care Lesotho
alright so this is a
this is this is the the gaffer looking
for a here
however we make the red match for some
let this drop
they're going to combine together so
that the person is a smooth at 1-over
then without malcolm Walker
and lose the not much
a little better this that appear
but no way to get it together right away
the one thing he admires when they're
whenever you make this but have a match
is the girl that same color so you can
usually start to panic with that color
pretty quickly if you go to do that
though
just some
after each mass just look around the
board to make sure you don't miss a
thing
to
it also gets a little bit harder to see
you whatever
there's a lotta grown person around to
see a little extra time
the Blues /url their got this big I know
either all spread out pretty bad
from this gonna go ahead and continue
Charlie
whether the the try to get apparent are
can't match any euros together
directly
clear this road to YouTube video the war
we did
take the Blues we have 'em
the couple
this is all that stuff here so we can
really mess through it
so we'll switch things up see what
happens love the color theory
your no as early level 95 where you can
do that in cattle are your matches in
the
in the Cascade but that can happen to
you know yet it's better than
movie things are for
Fisher are two you do we have like
mostly get here
really care we can't do anything
together we have happened here
if we can get to the papers to drop that
way
with the but other than that it's pretty
much
there's pretty much nothing your hand
move those together and now we have the
the fifth for me here forget closer
we go
kinda it's kind of a bummer only think
that we had them at
win we had a dream run together but we
want to be able to get that was
definitely the
I guess so there's really not that much
reason to 'em try to save those matches
unless you know you know for sure you
can
you can make your matching the without
here
work around it but I want me
I went way smoother because it's got a
the board's gonna switch up
no matter what you do too as things
although for their part summer gets here
the
you know we could
try to move some so green peppers this
row
but we also have a lotta
larger per person around so
amor lose to get their very to the to
see
if a thing materializes here can't
really go my way the verge
or
the want to merge if you want a groom
blue this
I mean I can I can slow the the greenery
the
I the one thing I'm kinda afraid others
that
by if I start to panic with cream no
bring
their economy is many green peppers at
Baltimore I'll
you can see that most the red ones are
growing the loans are grown so those are
going to be the ones that are left
behind after
so I guess in a way it doesn't matter a
all those green peppers really a clear
anyways
the can hold my breath what's in that
order area
all right now is near purple we have the
gap to rate here
the
we have part of it though here
only problem is we make this message
that over here
really get some matches and some other
things here
and we're gonna lose the war but I'll
so we also have it right here which we
can set up
directly that's probably going to be the
easiest on the work with
a on the go ahead and see if we can
cater reverend
or purple on the drop rate and first or
them
we don't have we don't we all have like
that agree
match to drop or here wanna do is
are and get 'em mess the purple that's
gonna drop some things the
it's also to keep this red one in place
I can I can try one more time
and we won't lose or get here so alright
to the
merit in this forget about that there
it that green other way
know he could drop the purple the its
gonna mess with this one so that the
or
mmm
we can make it here
which may be the best thing to do Hurley
get the
trying to get a blue one over here so
that I can
clears the get the performance go
and that's it so you can see that if you
plan it out
I'm you can actually work your way
through
takes awhile Minister 12-minute video
are
I woulda I wish economy and all that
shorter but with her or other things
if you have any questions about that
movement
the or then leave a comment and let us
know
hope this helps you out I know the first
reliable but
take a break we need to end this focus
on set up those things and
those gaps in your then forget it okay